guitares percussions plantes c'est la
composition atypique de cette formation
musicale
[Musique]
chacun suit sa partition les musiciens
jouent avec les impulsions électriques
de la plante grâce au capteur a posé sur
ses feuilles ces capteurs sont reliés à
un petit boîtier ici qui a dirigé dans
l'ordinateur
on lui donne un son soin de piano soit
de violon soit de guitare ce qu'on veut
après elle entre en réaction quand on la
touche quand on joue avec elle quand un
langage avec elle quand on a une
discussion avec elle elle va s'exprimer
libre de s'exprimer laplante improvise
ses propres mélodies le dio les a
enregistrées pour en faire l'un des
titres de son premier album est en
studio comme sur scène le végétal a
carte blanche cette plante là elle avec
nous depuis deux jours on constate que
au fur et à mesure des journées elle
chance sa manière de jouer de la musique
avec nous donc à chaque fois c'est
quelque chose de nouveau si la plante
elle peut pas faire de musique on peut
rien faire c'est un invité
complètement
imprévisible c'est pire qu'un musicien
de jazz en fait dans le cadre d'une
résidence artistique
le groupe a passé trois jours à saint
benoît du sault il y a rencontré des
classes de primaire et de collège avant
de se produire à l'occasion d'un concert
c'est un groupe qui en devenir vieux
si on a un rôle en tant que
l'association culturelle c'est d'essayer
déjà de trouver l'argent pouvoir
financer une résidence et puis après
c'est leur permettre de d'aller plus
loin quoi
le groupe poursuivre sa recherche de
sonorités nouvelles à l'avenir il se
verrait bien composé en pleine nature
avec des arbres
[Musique]